vu du ciel marioupol ressemble à une
immense ruine la ville au bord de la mer
d'azov et pourtant le dernier verrou
entre la crimée et les zones tenues par
les séparatistes que russe dans le noir
pour le faire sauter les renseignements
américains croient que moscou pourrait
utiliser des armes chimiques
oui
nous avons eu des informations crédibles
selon lesquelles les forces russes
pourraient utiliser différentes armes
anti émeutes notamment des gaz
lacrymogènes mélangés avec des agents
chimiques
des symptômes puissant pour affaiblir et
neutraliser les combattants mais aussi
les civils ukrainien dans leur campagne
agressive faut prendre mario paul lundi
l'armée de terre ukrainienne féliciter
ces soldats qui tiennent héroïquement la
ville une résistance qui pourrait
pousser la russie allait plus loin selon
le président ukrainien
l'un des porte-parole des envahisseurs a
déclaré qu'il envisageait d'utiliser des
armes chimiques contre les défenseurs de
marioupol nous prenons cela très au
sérieux
interdite par le droit international les
armes chimiques provoque des troubles
neurologiques et respiratoires
durant la guerre en syrie le régime de
bachar al assad est soupçonnée d'en
avoir utilisé accusations réfutées
aujourd'hui par vladimir poutine
les occidentaux ont mis en scène des
provocations en syrie ils ont dit que le
gouvernement du président assad utiliser
des armes chimiques il s'est avéré que
c'était un fait
le même fait qu'aujourd'hui à bout de
charbon ché selon le dernier recensement
des autorités ukrainiennes les combats
et bombardements ont fait au moins vingt
mille morts uniquement dans la ville de
marioupol